erhalten ist schon gar nicht die falsche
richtung lief antreten
nein im kanton jura was geht hier ist
euer kran ii und heute spielen wir
rocket league ich habe später den namen
vergessen
ich spiel das zum allerersten mal
natürlich mit dabei stürmer für es geht
und ich spiele das zum allerersten mal
und ich habe auch zum allerersten mal
ein spiel was ich mit controller spielen
kann an meinem pc und wollen wir
irgendwie uns ein spiel geht nicht
direkt also empfang direkt an aber geht
um nichts also besonders und frei ist
okay ich hab ihr können wir das
auswählen der dauert noch ganz gut ich
kann mir kein gras außerdem für ein
freundschaftsspiel recht wie vieles was
man weiß
oder bin ich das recht er ist geradeaus
geht doch
ich suche gerade match moment irgendwie
läuft es besser
ich komme zurecht ok jetzt hab ich
schnell dann bist du dabei
nee dann sprich alleine nein ich schon
die ganze etwas tust du aber ich kann
mich gerade einfahren
warum machst du das nichtstun kurzem ihr
in die runde kommt es geht nicht einfach
in kürze der vertrieb ist dann fehlt
natürlich gehen jetzt gerade ins spiel
rein und ich bin schon einmal gefahren
bestehen wir alleine
wie sagst du direkt zum regenbogen us
open bringen
b naja fast eigentlich schon alles gut
ich musste ein bisschen leiser stellen
ich komme jetzt kommt mir regenbogen
nötigen punkte auf
ja und als klären alter und geklärt aus
dem weg auf geht's spiel spielte in die
mitte
bis so richtig grün schwierig es war
schrecklich viel spaß all das ist
richtig geil
das macht auch den zuschauern spaß und
jetzt kommt er spielte mir eigentlich
gerade was mir gehalten und jetzt
junge junge junge
ich weiß an der wand ganz klar man kann
der wand lang fahren
man kann an der decke fahren ja schön
maschine sehr gut lässt wenn sie
aussteigen schritt würde das waren
schlecht nur angehört richtig ist
richtiges freunde des jetzt schon mein
lieblingsspiel
das macht auch schrecklich
steiger das thema rheinland pfalz die
ghanaer mit scheiße gott oh gott oh gott
der sie gut aus schlechte sind ich bin
im tor gosztonyi bestimme ich bin die
kanzlerin hatte ich mir über wandel
kommt jetzt
ab
man kann man irgendwie leute rahmen oder
so das ok kein mann kann dürften als
leute möchte es ist meine allererste
runde gerade im sponsoring durch
reingedrängt bin was wir da gesehen hat
wir uns selbst plant verdanken
papi ich bin scheiße aber du bist gut
der bisher dan alexa und ich habe immer
einen abend irgendwie richters besucht
ach das sind das in das zuschauer rein
geschrieben richtig guter schuss er kurz
mal über den titel weil du kannst halt
auch wenn du einmal springt und kann
sein hohes maß an consult fliehen
die antwort ist das coolste nein ich
komme hier an den ball ran
jetzt komme ich jetzt kann ich
ich bin rein machen der topscorer
wenn ihr neben die sind doch echt nicht
gut man was mir dass wir diese drei s11
ein alter so gut sind wir krass und wir
erhalten uns schon jakhrani falsche
richtung die volksrechte gerade kein tor
in eine komplett andere kommt danach
noch probleme sind und wer kommt für
unseren verein
ich will auch noch ein tor schießen
freunde du kannst hast ich probieren
vorzulegen freunde wir machen das jetzt
okay das macht voll spaß macht richtig
spaß
bedenklich findet erik bei dem fuß macht
eigentlich hätten eigentlich treffen
nein nein nicht richtig angeschlossen
ich kam so richtig übertrieben
angeschlossen
ja und ich mal fand wechselt falls
nichts für mich ist wenn es investoren
gibt die klären denn schon ganz gut
selber wieder raus wo gott helfen ein
usb stick das war richtig gut oder essig
der schuss war einfach habe ich was
falsch gemacht kommt man überhaupt nicht
gut man hätte ihn einfach rüber kommt
der aufbau das war so crazy
ich wollte den leuten gerade retten
haben die mitte nutze bewusst
was jetzt bitte bitte vom sturm
ich hoffe dass du hast so eine schlechte
kontrolle über den ball
er ist einfach total gewöhnungszeit ja
kommt in die mitte
ich drücke ich den besser vorgelegt weil
zunächst die rallye auf einmal aus oder
wer macht so richtigen ein bubble
überschlägen ein kompletter in rage
junge du sollst den ball dahinter
erwiesen
verrückter nein ich hab mich auch
versprungen
mein gott um hilfe zu bitten
jetzt schaue mir das an der wand irland
kommt schon im tor schießen ähnlich
antwortet ein tor 33
was machen wir in gronau oder so echt
spannend naja wenn das waldreichste ganz
gold wohl studidoo.de juli
ok deutschland machen lassen wenn du
kannst
man ist mit
nein nicht angekommen dieses darf so
hoch immer dabei ok nein nein nein das
war aber passen
diese schon wieder vorbei ist nicht gut
gewesen hätten es gut
den rand
jetzt hier mitte vorlage nein diese kann
den zug springen baustoffen ein denkmal
einmal die mitte er ist noch in der luft
so lange wir den luftkrieg spielt man
zwei matches oder 1 nur eins ist muss
bereit und kann so nächstes machen aber
es war richtig cool ich habe zwar kein
tor geschossen aber ich hatte echt ne
menge spaß
jackman sturm aus noch nicht hochgeladen
oder aber man nicht mal wieder wenn ihr
wollt dass sich über und das nochmal
spielstationen kommentare und dann
zement wieder drastisch geht auch jetzt